j'ai des choses à vous dire des choses à
vous dire ce que c'est vrai que cette
année ça a été une année compliquée
c'est vrai pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé et je voulais vous remercier vous
déjà d'avoir été là mais chéri de
n'avoir rien lâché d'avoir fait
l'émission 100 public pendant toute une
partie de la nuit vraiment c'était plus
compliqué que d'habitude
et franchement je voudrais vous dire
merci je vais faire les remerciements
maintenant parce que à la fin de
l'émission il y avait il plus ailleurs
et ses galeries d'art est un bordel pas
comme 10 des samistes 1 finit plus de
remercier tous les gens au travail et
moi avec cette émission je voudrais
remercier bien entendu lionel stan le
directeur général de h 2 o qui a fait un
magnifique travail de navigation avant
de remercier je voudrais remercier mon
cas combes et je voudrais remercier bien
entendu des eaux exceptionnelle nourrir
[Applaudissements]
toutes les équipes de programmation à
lecce s'ils votent ils cherchaient à
ballaigues sa mort les auteurs
dramatiques et bien entendu ça bien de
l'être
mon fidèle à toi qu'on livre bien sûr et
tous les gens qui ont travaillé sur les
missions de remercier mon loïc mon bras
droit qu'à lire mon bras gauche
et bien sûr comme sam rigo ce nom mais
[Rires]
ils ont permis de faire cette émission
je vous le dis tous les champs tous les
cadreurs vous les réalisateurs toi les
gens région et les cadreurs et tous les
cadreurs crises sont là je voudrais vous
dire les chéris c'est vrai qu'on est
devenus une famille où je regarde
souvent pendant l'émission
et c'est vrai qu'on qui fait qu' on se
regarde et comme souvent on rigole
ensemble et ça fait du bien voilà je
voulais vous dire et il ya un cadre
arrière qui est venu me voir à qui m'a
dit merci mon cyril de nous avoir donné
du travail cette année c'est plutôt moi
qui vous remercie parce que vous avez
été formidables merci motion
[Applaudissements]
enrisy tous les biens surtout la toule
hmc bien sûr accepter ce qui veut dire
maquillage coiffure je vous remercie
donc soria et toutes ses équipes
vu la gueule que j'ai je vais pas
tellement remercier le match mais c'est
bon c'est chez moi vers sinon va
remercier tout le monde ça va durer des
hommes et remercier bien sûr toutes les
équipes de sécu à tour de mokhtar mon
chéri au delson aussi la sécu deux
cadors sont mes potes cédric c'est un
pote c'est tous devenus mes potes je les
adore voilà je voulais dire j'en oublie
mis en appelant voilà qui font un
travail exceptionnel mais eric le
chauffeur de salle exceptionnelle
[Applaudissements]
avant mon chéri je vais remercier
également la chaîne parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a eu et je le dis à une liberté de
ton ici est incroyable
on fait ce qu'on veut on dit ce qu'on
veut jusqu'à ce qu'on nous foute dehors
c'est vrai c'est quand même exceptionnel
lors la machine
c'est vrai je sais bien sûr paul mendy
voudrais remercier tous les gens de la
conformité je remercie alex israël doit
verser mon garçon pujol je voudrais
inverse il faut que j'en oublie il faut
que je vais bien sûr après je vais
passer un à mon frérot franck appietto
mon président que j'aime il le sait à
qui voilà qui on peut tout dire c'est
vrai que c'est un bonheur que j'aime mon
franc qui à mon sens capitaux d'un mot
mon gérald brice viret notre président
maxime saada
notre autre président voilà gérald et
maxime qu'ils savent que je les aime 1
30 k doré aussi qui travaillent avec
nous et de grands patrons aussi qui est
toujours un amour
moi je vous dis avec nous voilà donc
tout le monde je voudrais remercier tout
le monde pouvait remercier bien entendu
vincent bolloré aussi qui m'a jamais
lâché et qui est toujours là qui est
notre grand patron voilà et je veux
remercier tous les gens qui nous aident
à faire cette émission et surtout
j'aimerais remercier vraiment jeudi le
public et les gens qui sont venus ils
sont revenus dès qu'ils ont clos venir
et je vais vous dire quand on avait pas
de public de voir des messages le soir
de voir sur les réseaux tous les
messages que vous nous avez laissé les
gens qui reviennent aujourd'hui est de
voir ça a été une année compliquée pour
nous au début de l'année c'est là qu'on
la fait pas mal de changements
les audiences étaient un peu poussive
pour ne pas dire dégueulasse
[Rires]
et c'est vrai que non mais c'est vrai et
je vais vous dire et je pense que vous
êtes ici témoins je n'ai jamais douté
jamais de là la force du programme et
c'est vrai qu'on a fait des petits
changements puisque on allait me la
prendre à l'essai après touche pas à mon
poste on avait fait un pari et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui touche pas à mon
poste c'est une marque tellement forte
c'est un rendez-vous tellement
incontournable que on s'en est même pas
rendu compte nous mêmes et c'est grâce à
bout quand on est rendu compte
donc aujourd'hui s'ils touchent pas au
poste cartonne c'est un parce que vous
nous avez ouvert les yeux et deux parce
que vous êtes au rendez-vous tous les
soirs de plus en plus nombreux sachez
que sur les trois derniers mois
depuis 2016 les audiences n'ont jamais
été aussi haute les chéris
voilà merci à vous
et je voudrais dire qu'on a on a des
nouvelles personnes qui nous ont rejoint
aussi dans touche pas à mon poste
et c'est vrai quoi là on a un virage
éditorial qui fait qu'on rigole beaucoup
et aussi où se traitent des sujets
importants de l'actuelle jugé important
de au vue de l'échéance 2022 qui arrive
de aussi resserré sur l'actu donc c'est
vrai qu'on rigole énormément comme sur
l'émission d'hier énormément rigoler
d'avant-hier aussi tous les jours mais
c'est vrai qu'aux six autres est de
d'énormément de sujets d'actu mon essai
des traités autrement voilà qu ailleurs
donc vous comment vous êtes senti mes
chéris est-ce que vous avez un mot à
dire sur cette fin d'année les chebs que
vous êtes tous là ce soir pour les
principaux bien entendu vous serez tous
là la saison prochaine avec moi je veux
bernard montiel venir il a été tricotée
cet après-midi la primeur ben moi je
dire j'aime beaucoup l'émission de cette
année puisque c'est les années passées
d'accord parce que là on est à la fois
dans la tare cas au début on s'amuse on
est très à l'aise on peut plaisanter et
à la fois on a dit sujet grave qui
intéresse tout le monde que l'on traite
avec les gens qu'il faut et qui font
l'actu chaque fois et ça j'apprécie
énormément tu me désaltère un nom mais
j'adore aussi c'est vrai que cette année
on a moins parlé télé je laissais plutôt
parce qu'il n'y a pas de nouveauté de
franchement chaque année c'est toujours
qu'elle empêche toujours les mêmes
programmes
tu veux dire un truc un jour il ya
mcneill maxime saada qu'est un pote
inquiet le président du directoire du
groupe canal et qui m'a dit mon cyril il
marque les deux semaines après la
rentrée il m'a dit tu crois pas qu'on va
avoir un problème avec la télé et c'est
vrai que si on est aujourd'hui bien sûr
on va le traiter
elle se renouvelle moi je vous dirais
d'ailleurs l'année prochaine dès 18h45
il y aura les 15 minutes médias avec un
chroniqueur qui vient à nous rejoindre
tous les jours pourparlers immédiats un
chroniqueur que vous connaissez vous
connaissez bien des dents dans l'équipe
de touche pas à mon poste qui nous
rejoindra tous les jours il fera le
quart d'heure mais tu es avec nous puis
il sortira et vous allez voir qu'il y
aura des nouveautés bien entendu l'année
prochaine mais pas de révolution
sachez le sur l'émission voilà quelques
nouveautés il y aura aussi un truc qui
va s'appeler fdp
les pétitions suit tous les soirs à
20h10 il aura les fdp s'appellera les
flingueurs du paf aux joints les rites
je pense que fabrice vision frappe à ta
voix la hauteur sur l'émission comment
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment sur
l'année valérie moelleux sans jamais y
rajoute un truc pas mal et moi je me
suis vraiment régalé à voir des sujets
importants avoir des prises de bec des
vrais il ya eu des vraies embrouillé
avec les rythmes de ceux de télé et
c'est vrai que je suis content qu'on ait
à détourner les missions même si on
parle encore de t d parce que c'est
plutôt intéressant
ok merci moi à titre personnel un mot
c'est merci parce que ça a été une année
un peu plus délicate pour moi ça a été
une année où je suis un peu serait
vraiment j'étais à 2000% j'ai eu un coup
d'arrêt en milieu de 20 ans milieu de
rentrée et donc merci à vous parce que
on s'est beaucoup parlé et on a beaucoup
dialogué moi je vous ai dit je ne sais
pas mentir donc je peux pas venir en
n'étant pas bien parce que je trouve que
ça va se voir et je veux pas mentir aux
téléspectateurs et et je me sens pas
bien de faire semblant c'est à consommer
par les amis on a une image dans la loge
avec valérie elle a fait un petit break
un moment il ya eu plein de l'arctique
qui ont dit oui
cyril hanouna et valérie belling se
fâcher la voilà donc vous voyez comme
quoi ouais voilà voir les ardennes mais
virer il t'avait virilo ville valérie
parce qu'ils en avaient besoin
je pense que cela t'a fait énormément de
bien parce que j'ai retrouvé le plaisir
de venir ici et ne pas faire semblant ce
que je ne supporte pas et je pense que
tu es spectateurs le voit quand on fait
semblant
et puis merci aux copains parce qu'ils
m'ont laissé la place chaude et qu'ils
ont tous été là ils m'ont appelé m'ont
envoyé des mots on se voyait
régulièrement été reversée à la chaîne
aussi qu'ils étaient là et présentent
donc merci et aux téléspectateurs parce
que j'ai reçus pendant cette période là
aussi plein de messages en disant quand
est ce que tu viens plus pourquoi est ce
que tu viens moi et c est ça aussi
ils se rendent pas compte à quel point
c'est important aussi pour nous ce qu'on
a une vie en dehors de l'émission je le
vis dans l'émission on a une vie en
dehors et leur message
quand on rentre chez soi ça fait
énormément de bien je vous dis merci à
vous c'est grâce à vous qu'on a pu faire
cette saison je vous le redis encore une
fois et c'est vrai que vous avez déjà en
mai montrent bien
j'étais pas là physiquement c'est vrai
que ça nous a fait du bien
nicolas pernikoff nouveaux venus écouter
merci déjà de m'avoir fait confiance de
m'avoir accueilli parce que c'est vrai
que tpm pc n'aurait famille les gens
sont bienveillants et gentil et puis de
l'autre côté il ya quand même une chose
importante s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'avaient pas la parole sont venus
s'exprimer sur le plateau et il ya
beaucoup de sujets et de problèmes de
société qui ont pu justement avancé
grâce à l'émission alors c'est un peu
bizarre n'en parlez moi puisqu'on fait
partie de cette équipe tous ensemble
mais je pense que s'il n'y avait pas eu
cette parole donnée à ces gens qu'on ne
voit pas et qu'on entend pas je ne sais
pas si je serai pas encore plus loin
dans cette escalade de la violence de
l'incompréhension donc le bravo à tous
d'avoir dû traiter de ces sujets puis
bravo aussi aux équipes de production
d'avoir permis à cette émission traiter
de sujets de société très important on
voit bien encore hier ou avant-hier
puisqu'on a traité du sujet du prix en
la république on traite des sujets
différemment et ce soir eric gaillard
c'est important de le traiter donc bravo
bravo très important
quelle idée de bellis bas - demande
souvent comment se passe le milieu du
showbiz et baby zara moi je le connais
pas parce que moi j'ai l'impression
qu'ici c'est pas le showbiz moi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une position fait
pas chaud c'est divin chauny la pression
d'avoir une famille sur ce coup là c'est
ma quatrième année et en cette quatrième
année je trouve sincèrement qu'on a eu
une équipe mais des plus bienveillante
du monde
on a faim les coulisses était apaisée je
trouve que cette satanée a été fabuleuse
on s'est serré les coudes quand ça
n'allait pas comme vous l'avez dit
c'était c'était une année complètement
bizarre un petit peu difficile
j'ai trouvé que qu on était vachement
ensemble tous ensemble
même avec les nouveaux avec steevy fin
moi j'ai passé une année merveilleuse et
je suis je suis trop heureuse notre
homme dans ma quatrième année les bains
bravo bravo madame non je suis contente
cyril ça fait dix ans vous ne changez
pas vous êtes toujours aussi tard et
c'est ce que j'aime je vous adore
insupportable de censure temps mais
j'aime bien et voilà dix ans
ben vous me rappeler à chaque fois je
suis toujours là non et des personnes
extraordinaires et c'est ce qui fait
aussi que ça fonctionne autour de moi
que les personnes exposées vous avez du
mal à dessiner autour de la table à part
guillaume genton
pour guillaume connaît merci en tout cas
pas dire à gilles verdez en fait je suis
plus en plus fier de faire partie de
cette aventure pour un coût donc merci a
vous de me laisser débattre de manière
enflammé souvent j'adore ça donc je suis
hyper content est vraiment bravo à vous
et aux équipes parce que c'est
l'émission dont on parle l'émission où
il faut être
c'est là que ça débat c'est là que les
choses avancent c'est là que on le verra
une bonne partie à mon avis de la
campagne présidentielle se jouera donc
bravo à vous d'avoir su renouveler
l'émission et d'en avoir fait un lieu de
plus en plus incontournable et je suis
très fier de participer à cette aventure
il a fait et il a bien il ya deux choses
qui me fascine vraiment c'est devant moi
les chiffres je les regarde tous les
matins et c'est un vrai plaisir
alors il faut avoir le courage de le
dire l'audience l'écart nettement
diminué entre vous et tmc
et il ya des pointes qui sont
phénoménales et honnêtement
effectivement septembre je savais qu'il
y aurait une progression parce que
chaque année via une production alors
que chaque année elle a réservé aussi
nette la pression de tout et c'est vrai
que tous les ans en novembre décembre
tout le monde dit bon bah c'est fini
mais je rappelle moi dès la deuxième
saison et c'est vrai que là on a connu
une saison incroyable et c'est vrai que
les médias soulignent que les chiffres
en revanche les médias dits sérieux ont
beaucoup plus souligné le phénomène
hanouna et dont le coût sans se [ __ ]
de la gueule du phénomène en disant
qu'il fallait prendre en compte moi en
tant que journaliste médias ça
m'interpelle comme ils disent dans les
colloques et le deuxième truc qui me
on a eu de très beaux articles oui merci
les gars de lundi parce que moi je fais
mes petites multitude un mois
si des cyber sécurité pour leurs douze
comme vous ne passez pas la parole je
suis absolument fasciné par vaux
fulgurances notamment dans les débats
politiques face à jean missia face dans
balances ton post c'est que oui mais sa
façon même quand vous sur gueuler de
dédramatiser le truc et moi défense dit
[ __ ] [ __ ] ça va repartir dans les
salles ça va partir et non il ya
toujours un moment où on casse le truc
de trop ça redescend mais moi ça me
fascine absolument téléphone utiles et
ce n'est pas me tromper
elle a connu toutes les saisons là bas
merci à toi machine ça me ferait si ce
sera avec nous l'année prochaine via la
toile ou trois mois et qui ont fait un
travail exceptionnel réalisé
j'aimerais que vous vous présentiez
apparent téléspectateurs et vous nous
disiez si vous êtes là avec moi l'année
prochaine ou pas pour moi c'est très
important le mans démarré par a démarré
comme ça on va démarrer panneau là alors
il dit peut dire je m'appelle amaury et
normalement je suis l'année prochaine je
serai les prochaines je peux pas faire
mieux
on a rappelé que tu perdes on dit voilà
donc je suis chargé de prod c'est une
banque ça veut dire vivre de mon
dictionnaire il ya une heure de
l'en-tête vous lui demandez un chameau
et va t'amener à chapeaux mais c'est
entre nous tu dis à chameau qui bégaye
km messieurs
[Applaudissements]
pour dérapage sera pas là l'année
prochaine merci pour la réponse marion
[Applaudissements]
est celle qui était aussi alors je vous
dis un truc parce que je ne fais jamais
le répète ouais et dans à prendre ou à
laisser il faut faire des répètes pour
les caméras et donc comme je ne fais pas
de répit c'est elle qui fait
l'animatrice et un jour jetons en fait
je d'emballage et je regardais jamais
elle ne fait pas mieux pour cette opa
est donc celle réanimer à prendre
d'essai pour les répète et après noël
c'est clair ils font le jeu en entier et
sur les répétitions
c'est à dire mais moi j'étais comme ça
il y a j'ai adoré j'ai adoré a présenté
à prendre
j'espère va tu sais c'est à son cousin
change toujours l'animation de cette
émission dont kg la sacre historique
part bien sûr de cheran dès lundi à
l'eba la prochaine ce sera peut-être
dans les prochaines semaines
oui je serai là
et mon bébé ça c'est mon bébé parce que
il est là comme amour rien c'est vrai ça
c'est des bébés ça va mon chéri d'amour
un truc alors présente toi
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
quatre ans et demi oui je suis là est
exceptionnel et 320 m haies le sud est
est ce que tu sera avec nous l'année
prochaine non maman oui ça bah c'est que
normalement c'est moi normalement
alors ça c'est l'argent tu seras pas là
si c'est normalement il sera là bien
entendu mon chéri magnifique merci
également aux bovins sont plus jeunes
dames et directeur des programmes que
jambes est tous les matins voilà je
voudrais dire et qui a garé son que
j'aime il le sait qui est un garçon
formidable c'est le directeur des
programmes de ces vite et je peux vous
dire pour me supporter tous les matins
il faut qu'il soit et on lève vraiment
il est il est formidablement vincent
chéri d'amour juste éveil des remercier
également les stylistes y en a vu là
aucun doute à l'heure il ya delphine
bataille à katyn si voilà valentin
kakikouka travail magnifique
voilà ne regardez pas benjamin castaldi
ce soir c'est pas eux qui s'en sont
occupés elle est magnifique sur le jazz
west ham s'est rétréci ces mecs ne sais
pas qui c'est mais c'est très beau voilà
je ne vais pas ils sont une petite
remarque c'est que ça s'écrit sans trop
d'enjeu même sandra du parti centriste
merci dieu les séries on est en train de
faire un tour de table pour savoir un
peu le sentiment de chacun et juste
après on fera ça on danse j'ai une
petite fille géniale les chéris éplucher
une surprise public et j'ai une surprise
également pour bernard montiel puisqu'il
saura oui oui surprise pour vous
j'espère généralement elles sont bonnes
en tout cas elles sont bonnes pour les
téléspectateurs exact on était à stevie
moore qui vient d'arriver
comment tu t'es senti mon chéri elle va
écouter moi franchement c'est un vrai
moment de bonheur
ah oui j'ai fait plusieurs équipes avec
laurent avec vous et franchement c'est
je suis assez ému parce que ils ont tous
été très gentils et des jets vont tous
bien accueilli votre public les fans 12
et des appareils
ils m'ont soutenu qui m'ont accompagné
et c'est là même qui vous ont
raccompagné j'aime attendre
je m'attendais pas à ça pour être
honnête j'avais très peur quand tu
arrives et c'est vrai que j'étais
tétanisée bas vous êtes quand même tous
impressionnants vous êtes tous des
monstres c'est vrai alors si on est bien
tous comme ça que vous êtes gentil mais
ce sont des mondes ah oui oui vous êtes
qui c'est très impressionnant pour
quelqu'un de lambda donc forcément oui
je demande à ce que moi j'étais je vous
regarde depuis des années en plus c'est
pas comme si je connaissais pas ces
groupes avec certains et cetera donc les
voir en vrai sympathise avec eux en fait
il était telle que je me suis imaginé
très sympathique mais pour moi c'est un
vrai moment de bonheur merci pour ce
très vieux - filippo jamila d'or qui
j'ai eu un vrai coup de coeur pour
steve-o tant professionnelle que
rejoindre l'asie tous les jours ma mère
si elle aime vraiment beaucoup il le sec
et le stress et proc merci mon chéri
delphine olala delphine alors à delphine
aussi elles l étaient partis l'an
dernier et à la fin retour en fait ça
nous a fait ce qu'on appelle dans le
métier maintenant une benhaim
[Rires]
c'était un truc dans penser pouces mais
delphine ali c'est beaucoup plus éclaté
cette année ah bah ouais moi ah oui
c'est vrai oui oui pas de sérieuses
parce que bon on change tous
et puis l'émission aussi a changé et
effectivement aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe sur l'émission c'est plus juste du
divertissement c'est pas qu'un programme
télé c'est ce et c'est ici que ça se
passe pour la politique pour les gens
les enjeux de société c'est fantastique
donc je suis très très fier de faire
partie de votre équipe et de pouvoir
voilà à travers la caméra pouvoir parler
aux gens de certains sujets aussi qui me
touche ça avec elle il ya des sujets qui
me touchent plus que d'autres et je vous
ai déjà une fois écrit un retour des
missions en disant juste merci cyril pas
le fait que je sois chronique et
automates abl mais merci peut-être sur
les animaux bien longue oui voilà
c'était la toute première fois sur la
face voilà et et et on s'est écrit j'ai
dit merci pour ce que j'ai pu réaliser
parce que selon moi c'est la petite
fille qui parle est donc juste merci
merci de tout ça ces mois d'été avait
fait une très belle saison avec nous
l'année prochaine
bien entendu encore plus voilà comme
vous culte sans fin ne seraient pas tous
encore plus voilà voilà
c'est les murs allez encore un autre qui
nous a fait une benhaim vraiment
si un truc pareil pareil nom pareil que
malgré moi je suis je suis vraiment
content parce que cette émission en
début de saison
l'adn de tpm paix que je regardais mois
chez moi c'était du chocolat c'était
rigoler avec les gens s'étaient juré
perruque c'est aller dans la rue comme
on l'a fait là avec cette crise
sanitaire qui nous a tous plombés on a
été obligé de mettre ces [ __ ] de truc
là et de faire un truc carré et les gens
se sont plaints sur twitter on dit c'est
plus comme avant ça a changé
mais l'émission elle a super bien changé
de 900 me tue 10 et de soleure 908 et
spectateurs c'est monté crescendo
vous avez été à la hauteur parce qu' il
fallait tenir les intervenants vous avez
fait l'actualité en faisant venir des
gens qui avaient pas la parole et
l'émission allait monter tout doucement
et l'intelligence que j'ai aimé moi
c'est que au début de saison les gens
ont dit l'émission on aime pas il faut
changer s'il faut changer ça et vous
avez écouté les gens et vous avez changé
avec les boîtes etc etc et moi c'est
pour ça que je suis vraiment fier de
cette aventure d'été pmp de ce que de ce
qui s'est passé je n'oublie pas non plus
bas bas le zumba bas que vous aviez fait
au début qui était qu'ils étaient très
forts aussi je suis fier d'avoir
participé à ça je n'oublie pas c'est que
du kif qu'on avait fait dans une série
en avion je suis très fier la volonté le
pilote de koh lanta qu'on avait c'était
extraordinaire est vraiment arriver à
ces chiffres là pendant confinement 1,6
1,7 et les gens qui nous ont pas lâchés
moi ce que je devrais remercier c'est
les chroniqueurs qu'on fait un boulot
extraordinaire mais surtout les gens à
vivre les gens qui nous ont pas lâchés
on était tout le temps là pour nous
faire des compliments moi quand j'ai
fait ma beinheim les gens m'ont dit que
j'étais viré
non je vais l'accueillir et expressions
j'ai juste jusque là ben ali mais moi je
voudrais te remercier pascal ou non en
fait ce qui se passe c'est comme quand
vous attendez un enfant vous avez peur
de mourir alors moi quand je n'ai pas
beaucoup d'argent je n'ai pas peur de
mourir
eric vous maintenant j'ai un peu peur de
mourir parce que j'ai un petit une deux
côtés
[Applaudissements]
on rencontre les gens et aux rencontres
même des gens tu t'attendais pas j'ai
rencontré le mec des impôts moi parce
qu'il m'a dit en 2020 faisait super bien
travaillé le mec deux impôts les vues
chez moi et du coup maintenant je fais
beaucoup d'impôts je suis très fier
grâce à vous tirer c'est à dire de payer
beaucoup d'impôts et bravo tu es pas un
bon jour il sera avec nous l'année
prochaine bien sûr mon raymond c'est ici
alors que j'ai alors moi c'est un régal
dans un contexte et sanitaires super
difficile en fait moi c'est un régal
parce que je suis mis tous les jours et
on va accepter une sorte de respiration
parce que je me rendais coin qui avait
plein de gens autour de moi qui
travaillais plus qu'ils travaillaient
pas qu'ils étaient voilà qui était
vraiment handicapé par cette situation
moi j'avais la chance de pouvoir venir
tous les jours bosser et en fait c'était
pour moi comme une sorte de bulle
sanitaire vraiment de retrouver tous les
gens l'équipe la famille on était soudé
c'est incroyable ça c'est l'aspect
personnel et après professionnellement
moi je me suis éclaté by the view parce
qu'en fait j'ai vu en fait mais je vous
ai vu d'abord comme la disait tout à
l'heure à la fois instinctif et intuitif
j'ai vous preniez le pouls de la société
de du pays
vraiment et j'ai trouvé que j'avais la
chance tous les jours de pouvoir dire ce
que je pensais comme je le voulais
maladroitement en tout cas avec mon
coeur est de pouvoir croiser dans la
même émission corbières qui croise loana
qui croise ortega qui croise booba qui
croient guaino là franchement ça a de la
gueule
c'est vrai qu'on est la raison l'a
résumé elle a résumé franchement merci
parce que je trouve que j'ai eu beaucoup
beaucoup de chance
voilà merci moi j'ai dit
merci macgé qui a fait une année
exceptionnelle et ou alors lui chante
la révélation de l'année ah ouais
scooter il est sublime je vais vraiment
remercier ma visagiste déjà qui a pris
soin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la fois gagner en éclats même pendant
que j'avais c'est vrai je suis assez
d'accord
sérieusement cyril de nous a permis de
travailler que ce soit à l'antenne ou en
production parce qu'il ya plein de gens
qui ont pas eu la chance de travailler
pendant le coït
et comme l'a dit géraldine on avait la
chance tous les soirs devenir d'avoir
une interaction avec des gens de voir
des gens il ya des gens qui étaient
vraiment déprimé chez eux donc en
remercie pour ça parce que sinon ça
aurait été vraiment dur voilà on s'est
régalé mon chéri merci et alors il ya
quelqu'un qui font beaucoup pour moi
également qu'il voulait dire un petit
mot
ces mots bon moment qu'il n'ya voilà qui
était un petit peu partie de la famille
tandis que la falaise d'ailleurs y est
la prairie soir voilà il a même sont
battus les uns seront balisés
penser le monde merci moment mots
d'amour ça va mon chéri d'amour moi ce
soir
oui ce que tu es là où tous les soirs il
a un bep naisy vous à tous deux équipes
merci merci du fond du coeur
grâce à vous un handicap
higgins et merizzi doute faut des clips
série d'edgar des deux frères des
commandes est ma deuxième famille
[Musique]
mercier
[Applaudissements]
quant à ciani alors bon moment c'est
vrai que c'est la famille et moment il à
abattre maintenant et c'est vrai que il
est avec nous et il sera avec nous bien
sûr l'année prochaine mon bureau que
j'aime et on ne quittera jamais on ne
lâchera jamais je sais que je t'aime mon
mot
et tu sais que tu es tu es partie de ma
famille voilà mon chéri merci en tout
cas je suis très ému de voir encore ce
soir